[Musique]
paris comme toutes les grandes villes
françaises se construit de grands et
beaux immeubles de bureaux sur tout et
parfois d'habitation mais sur 13000
construction neuve 11000 remplace des
immeubles détruits spécialement dans ce
but on démolit entièrement des quartiers
de paris
pas forcément insalubres pour faire du
neuf
chaque fois le coût de l'opération est
exorbitant paris de toute façon est cher
le prix des loyers a doublé largement
depuis 62 le prix du mètre carré 9 varie
actuellement de 4000 francs dans les
quartiers populaires à 25000 francs
deux millions et demi de centimes dans
les beaux quartiers paris devient une
ville bourgeoise une ville chère une
ville dessinée une population fortunée
il n'ya que voir les immeubles d
ni des bords de seine par exemple avec
le prix des loyers qui est absolument
inaccessible même beaucoup de français n
majorité des gens qui habitent ces
immeubles sont des
et des gens disent ambassades des gens
des grandes firmes internationales
c'est le résultat d'une politique qui
était la première politique gaullienne
de grandeur c'est à dire paris devait
être espérer qu'il soit la capitale de
l'europe donc en conséquence on voulait
faire une ville propre propre
c'est-à-dire débarrassée des taudis
débarrasser des immeubles non
vétuste et en même temps débarrassé des
gens aussi qui paraissait un peu sale
entre guillemets pour les étrangers qui
devait venir c'est à dire que paris
devait être une plateforme devait être
un espèce de miroir aux alouettes pour
attirer des centres comme rdd
des grandes compagnies étrangères le
résultat est loin d'être une réussite
on a effectivement construit des
milliers de bureaux des tours
ressemblant plus ou moins à celle de
manhattan à new york
mais beaucoup de ces bureaux ne sont ni
acheter ni louées à cause peut-être de
leur prix et surtout à cause de leur
trop grand nombre
on a aussi vider certains quartiers de
paris de leurs habitants montparnasse
par exemple la place d'italie
ce sont évidemment les familles modestes
qui ont été les plus touchés on a
laisser s'établir une véritable
ségrégation sociale en déportant les
habitants du centre vers la grande
banlieue et tout ceci au nom de l'argent
puisqu'il est incontestable que dans la
construction ce qui fait grimper les
prix de façon aussi vertigineuse
c'est la spéculation immobilière et
surtout foncière les terrains dans paris
et les grandes villes de france en
devenu prohibitif et c'est un scandale
parce que le gouvernement depuis la
libération tous les gouvernements n'ont
jamais voulu toucher au droit de
propriété
il est anormal que les terrains des
propriétaires qui ceux qui ont fructifié
grâce aux réseaux de communication gaza
tout l'équipement trou de ces terrains
donc à la collectivité ne reviennent pas
la collectivité et c'est ça qui fait
grimper le prix des appartements des
logements dans paris les grandes villes
de france
parce que les prix de revient des tours
que vous voyez ici sont exactement le
même que les prix de revient dans la
campagne de la beauce où la campagne
marseillaise célèbre même béton le même
faire les mêmes travailleurs immigrés et
français donc par contre ce n'est pas le
même prix de vente est pas le même prix
de location c'est un scandale
l'évidence est que seuls ceux qui ont
beaucoup d'argent peuvent se loger
confortablement dans la ville il y à 16
millions de français mal logés et quatre
millions d'entre eux vivent dans des
appartements surpeuplés
comment faire une politique du logement
cohérente sans une véritable politique
foncière
comment admettre que le nombre de
logements neufs inoccupés dans le centre
des villes augmente sans cesse et que
tous ceux qui manipulent l'argent pour
la construction le fasse fructifier
aussi vite
comment enfin accepté que le logement
qui est un droit soit si cher
la france les capitalistes français dans
le bâtiment sur tout de même beaucoup
plus gourmand que les autres il est
admis que cela rapporte entre 11 et 12%
toutes dépenses confondues les
honoraires d'architecte compris les
honoraires du notaire qui en touche
beaucoup d'ailleurs la publicité tandis
que dans les pays capitalistes de même
nature
l'allemagne de l'ouest le benelux
l'angleterre même la suisse c'est du 5 %
s'explique déjà beaucoup la dégradation
du cadre de vie en france les prix des
appartements du logement à l'étranger
capitaliste beaucoup moins cher déjà
qu'en france beaucoup moins élevé
ce n'est pas tout personne ne peut plus
garantir dans les villes des loyers et
des charges d'un niveau acceptable
les citadins sont maintenant contraints
de dépenser entre 30 et 40 % de leur
revenu pour se loger
l'idéal est entre 20 et 25% il faut
enfin ajouter que la concertation entre
le citoyen et celui qui construit
n'existe pas on maintient un certain
secret autour des enquêtes d'utilité
publique
les transactions sont souvent
clandestines les circuits financiers
complexes donner la parole et un certain
pouvoir à l'utilisateur est sans doute
le premier moyen de réduire les
inégalités
[Musique]